We're asked to simplify
7x plus 10 squared.
And your temptation when you see
something like this might
be to just make it 7x squared
plus 10 squared and that would
be incorrect.
Remember, when you're squaring
something, you're multiplying
something by itself.
So this wouldn't be 7x squared
plus 10 squared.
This is equal to 7x plus
10 times 7x plus 10.
This is not equal to-- sometimes
if you said this is
7x times 10 squared, then you
could say this is equal to 7x
squared times 10 squared.
You would be able to do it in
this situation right here.
But that's not what's
going on here.
This is 7x plus 10 squared,
which is just 7x plus 10 times
7x plus 10.
So let me delete
that up there.
That's probably the single
biggest point of confusion
when people first learn
to take a square of an
expression like this.
So always remember that it's 7x
plus 10 times 7x plus 10.
And now we can multiply
it out.
So one, we could distribute this
yellow 7x plus 10 onto
each of the terms into
the green one.
So it would be 7x plus 10
times 7x right here.
So we put the 7x out front.
And then we could say plus
7x plus 10 times 10.
Or we could say plus 10
times 7 x plus 10.
I just distributed the 7x plus
10 on each of these terms.
Then you do the distributive
property again.
7x times 7x is 49x squared.
7x times 10 is 70x.
And then you have 10 times
7x is another 70x.
10, which is 100.
Now, there's something
interesting you might want to
notice right now is that this
expression, it is the first
expression squared, right?
7x, the whole expression
squared is 49x squared.
And then you do have your
last expression squared,
10 squared is 100.
But then in between, you have
the product of these two
things twice, and that's just
a byproduct of having to do
all of the different
combinations of products.
So the end expression, when you
simplify everything, it
becomes 49x x squared
plus 140x plus 100.
So if you want to remember
a quick way of squaring a
binomial like this, and just
remember, it is coming out of
this distributive property, but
if you had to do it really
fast, it's just going to be this
first term squared, which
is that right there, plus 2
times the product of these two
terms. 7x times 10 is 70x,
and then you multiply it
by 2, you get 140x.
You get that right there.
And then the last term is just
going to be the square of the
second term right there.
10 squared is 100.